[Music]
okay everyone so i'm really excited
today because i am joined by olivia
taylor
dudley aka bonnie in some of our
stallions that comes out
this friday how you doing today olivia
i'm great i'm doing really good
how are you i'm i'm doing really good uh
what i was wondering about this film is
when you first
read the script for this film what drew
you to the part of
bonnie well i mean i'm always looking
for characters that are
really complex and um
i like to have a character that has some
edges and some
it is kind of in a dark place in their
life i think that's more interesting for
me it's always kind of what i'm drawn to
and bonnie is definitely at the
is not at a great place in her life and
we find her and
i just felt like you know she's kind of
the straight man in this story and
i like being a straight man while
everyone's being funny around
me because i can stay grounded and stay
really in
who this person is and i don't know i
think that carson's writing was just so
great the script made me laugh so hard
that i wanted to be a part of it i
didn't care
who i played but um luckily he had me as
bonnie
but yeah i don't know what really sold
me honestly the first scene when we
first meet bonnie she leaves
the institution and just gets in the car
with them
and doesn't ask any questions and that
when i read that i'm like who is this
woman that just like gets in a car with
strange men and doesn't ask questions
and it terrifies the men i was like yeah
i'm down i like
i like who she is no and it's such an
interesting character like you say and
and you portray it so
well i'm wondering in your portrayal of
bonnie
was there any other characters in media
or film that inspired that
kind of came from i'm sure there were at
the time
i can't think of any right now
no i just i just saw myself in here too
i think i as somebody who has struggled
with mental illness
as far as in my in my in my circle and
in my life
and myself struggling with some social
anxiety problems like
bonnie i don't know i just i related to
her immediately immediately that she was
kind of in her own shell
and those are the kind of characters
that i like playing
so when you're saying the kind of
character you like playing when you read
a script
is there any roles that are red flag to
you that you kind of won't take
no i mean i'm down for anything i've
played all kinds of characters but
my favorite and probably because it is
some sort of catharsis you know to play
somebody who
i'm very shy and introverted as a person
and
so i tend to gravitate towards those
characters because i know eventually
they won't be
normally in a script there's a journey
for them and so then maybe on the other
side of making something i will have
gone through the same journey and will
come out of my shell a little more
that's always the goal
but yeah oh i love that that's that's an
amazing answer
so also too with this film being an
indie project
can you kind of share the pros of doing
an indie film compared to doing
something like a paranormal activity
that you did
yeah i mean indie film is always where
my heart is at it's what i love doing
the most
um most of my friends are indie
filmmakers and
i just love the camaraderie and i love
you know everybody on set
is there because they want to be and
they love it and not that that isn't the
case on larger
projects but it's not as intimate and
it's sometimes not as rewarding as a
small movie can be
and you know i think that that's why
this movie works so well is because
everybody was
just like madly in love with each other
every day on set like we had the most
fun and we're all friends in real life
so
it's i think that that kind of energy
comes across on the projects and on
screen and i think it really did with
this one
yeah and you know you also what's cool
about you is you're a huge fan of film
and tv and you always share on like your
instagram stuff you're watching
do you now when you're in something like
magicians or a movie like this
do you run and go watch yourself are you
someone you can't really watch yourself
no i hate watching myself honestly okay
um no i have definitely seen i've seen a
few seasons of magicians but um
i have not watched all of it i can't
it's mostly because like i really just
love making the thing i love
the process of making it and being on
set that's that's why i do this
um the finished product is out of my
hands so sometimes it can be
heartbreaking but
i did watch stallions and i love it so
much i love it
so freaking much it turned out really
well i think and i'm really proud of it
so
um yeah no after the last year of being
quarantined you have to stare at our
faces on screens like i'm coming
over it yeah 100 and speaking of this
like crazy last year was it
hard to like work on your craft as an
actress when you're like in lockdown can
you kind of explain that
was there like a way you were kind of
just practicing if that makes sense
no i was pretty rough i mean my
therapist was always trying to come up
with ways she's like well why don't you
get dressed up in a costume and just
like dance through his house and i'm
like i do that anyway that's why i hired
you to get me to stop doing that
i um don't it was rough honestly but
out of it came a lot of cool things i'm
working on a lot of projects with
friends that we wrote during the
pandemic and um yeah you know a lot of
really great art will come out of this
so
you mentioned stuff you wrote are you
looking to get more into writing more
things and
would you ever consider directing yeah i
have i've written
um i used to write a lot of comedy you
had a web series for a long time years
ago
so i i have written and i i did direct a
short
right before pandemic that hopefully
will come out um
and i'm producing a couple movies right
now so i'm always having my hands and
and everything but
acting is what i love but i just love
filmmaking in general
sure and you know most people are going
to know you from magicians in that
amazing character of alice you played
now that it's sad that it's come to an
end would you though in your career if
someone was to offer you like
another steady role in tv would you
still consider that are you trying to
kind of go a different path at the
moment
no i would i think television is amazing
right now and you know we're in the
golden age of television and
i've i've been reading a lot of really
wonderful scripts lately
and i'm just like wow tv is it's really
thrilling and it's nice
it's also nice to have a job a
long-running job but i'm i'm
i hope i get to do a balance of both to
be honest like i'm in vancouver right
now about to start a
small movie and i hope i get to do more
movies like stallions and
more tv shows you know sure and and you
mentioned you do so many things which is
so true
and i love that you do a cameo for
charity which i think is awesome
uh but have you gotten any crazy
requests on cameo
yeah ones i'm not even gonna say but
yeah people have had some crazy requests
for sure yeah i love doing i love
doing videos for fans it's really fun
but um
some of them i definitely don't don't
accommodate yeah
no makes sense um also too you have a
beautiful horse you always share
pictures of
on instagram when did you start writing
riding horses has this been something
your whole life
yeah i've ridden since i was like five
so i've ridden my whole life my mom rode
horses and i've shown and bred and
trained horses my whole life and then
took a long break especially while
shooting magicians and then
when the last season of magicians i was
like if this i need to get a horse again
i need something that's not just work
and um yeah actually it's been a a major
savior during this past year is that the
only place i would go is the barn so
yeah love well that's awesome that's
that's really cool and
i got lucky you know yeah and people
here are watching who are huge fans of
you what would you say to them
why should on friday they rent you know
some of our stallions why should they
give this film a chance
i mean stallion some of our stallions is
one of the most unique
movies that i have seen and it i haven't
felt that way
when i watched the final version of the
movie it made me feel the same
excitement in my belly that i used to
get watching movies when i was younger
like i just seem like new and fresh
and characters that are not normally on
screen and
i don't know i was just like full of so
much excitement after watching it
and you don't always feel that when you
work on something but it was like
i don't know there's some sort of magic
in this in this movie that i hope people
will see and everyone who i know has
watched it has felt the same so whatever
that is carson you did a great job and
yeah i hope people really love it yeah
so you heard it from here
her right here that you know some of
your sound it's amazing i've seen it
myself i loved it
olivia you killed it here as bonnie so
everyone make sure to check this
out on friday on demand olivia thank you
so much for joining me today i hope to
talk to you in the future
mewtwo huh nice to meet you